today the Matt wall show a school
teacher sexually harasses his students
by wearing massive prosthetic breasts to
class but the school says that his
gender expression is protected and only
bigots would criticize him for it also
Joe Biden is asked whether he's running
for re-election then he doesn't exactly
say yes plus Bill Maher is accused of
Defending slavery in our daily
cancellation Math teachers tried to
explain why basic arithmetic is racist
all of that and more today on the Matt
Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
do you really control your retirement
savings if you've got a 401k or IRA the
government controls how much money you
can borrow when you have to pay it back
all of that plus you'll owe taxes and
penalties for taking money out too soon
or waiting too long even though it's
your money there's lots of rules
attached to it Bank on yourself though
is a better way to grow and to protect
your hard-earned money this this
retirement plan alternative has never
had a losing year in over 160 years Bank
on yourself offers guaranteed
predictable growth and retirement income
without any luck or guesswork required
your plan doesn't go backwards with the
market tumbled uh both your principal
and your growth are locked in the
strategy lets you take a tax-free
retirement income to protect you from
the incoming tax tsunami unlike a
government-controlled 401k or IRA you
control the money in your plan no
questions asked and without government
penalties or restrictions get a free
Report with all the details on how
adding Bank on yourself to your
financial strategy ads guarantees
predictability and control to your
financial plan so just go to bank on
your yourself.com slash Walsh that's
bankonyourself.com Walsh this
information is for educational purposes
only and it's not a solicitation for the
purchase of any Financial product all
guarantees are based on the claims
paying ability of the insurer
a little bit of sad news to begin the
week according to multiple media reports
a trans woman quote unquote has become
the victim of housing related
discrimination in Texas as The Story
Goes Shayla Anderson who's a male who
identifies as a female was targeted by a
transphobic and racist property manager
and then served a notice of eviction I
mean evicted all on the basis of being
trans all on the basis of sheer bigotry
that anyway is a story but as is so
often the case the story and the reality
don't exactly match up here's a local
news report with more details watch this
Shayla Anderson's home at the Grand
fountain in Richmond used to be her
Sanctuary when I first moved here it was
wonderful before the last two years the
worst thing I ever experienced in my
life Shayla says it started when she and
her husband made a noise complaint she
says it was never addressed by
management so she went to speak to the
property manager I went to her office
she said I'm not going to speak with you
about this I'm not going to speak with
you about this sir Shayla is a
transgender woman basically she took my
Womanhood and crushed it by calling me
sir Shayla says she contacted Sunridge
Management Group the company who owns
the apartment complex they never reached
out to me that's when she filed this
discrimination complaint with the U.S
Department of Housing and Urban
Development and she says the situation
got worse do you live here this video
went viral online she says it shows the
property manager questioning her husband
and son while playing basketball it was
a group of African-American men
in the basketball court playing
basketball
she felt that there were residents that
were not residents Shayla says the
property asked her to take the video
down and once she did she received an
eviction notice she says prior she
hadn't received any notices or Warnings
and her attorney's advised her not to
pay rent because of the ongoing
litigation
well that certainly looks like a
credible person doesn't it but looks can
be deceiving and sometimes also a little
bit disturbing although the reporter
tries her best to create a narrative
favorable to the trans person the
reality still peeks through here we find
out that the eviction notice was sent
after Shayla Anderson
stopped paying rent now everything else
in this whole Saga is effectively
Irrelevant in light of that relevant
fact if you don't pay rent
you get evicted Shayla claims that uh
attorneys advised against paying rent
because of ongoing litigation now if
that's the case then the lawyers here
are about as skilled and competent as
Anderson's plastic surgeon because you
know you can't sue your apartment
complex and then simply stop paying your
rent until the lawsuit is settled that's
just not how it works
but there's a statement made earlier in
the report that I think stands out and
is more
more to the point for us for our
purposes today Anderson says that when
the property manager used the word sir
uh she had quote taken my Womanhood and
crushed it
this is how it works now in our culture
it is it is your job to reinforce the
self-perceptions and fantasies of every
person that you meet
their validation has become somehow your
responsibility Anderson is clinging
desperately to a self-concept that is
fragile and and brittle and can be
broken into a million pieces crushed as
we're told by one simple three-letter
letter word now
no authentic real woman walks around
like this ready to dissolve into a
puddle if her Womanhood is not affirmed
I mean a real woman
doesn't need her Womanhood affirmed
that's because her Womanhood is not an
abstraction
okay it's not something that's just kind
of floating around in The Ether it is a
reality it's vibrant and true and alive
and solid and anyone who fails to
recognize it would be embarrassing
themselves not the other way around
with these kinds of solid realities are
not what we're expected to validate
indeed often those are exactly things
that were expected to invalidate to deny
our job so says the culture is to affirm
the fevered imaginations and egocentric
delusions of particular protected
classes of people
and although this story at the apartment
complex down in Texas is an instructive
example of this Dynamic it still pales
in comparison I think
to this
going up now North to Canada reading
from the new site redox it says photos
and videos out of a Canadian High School
are going viral as they show a male
teacher wearing what appears to be a
large prosthetic breasts in full view of
young students shocking media first
began to circulate on Twitter earlier
this week with multiple accounts sharing
a uh cell phone video and stills of a
shop teacher demonstrating how to use a
circular saw the teacher is seen wearing
an extremely prominent prosthetic bust
one which clearly outlines the nipples
through his tight shirt he's also
donning a bright blonde wig and short
shorts multiple photos and videos have
service of the same individual
instructing young students and in all of
them he's wearing the oversized bust the
media has been confirmed as originating
from Oakville traffic Trafalgar
Trafalgar I think right High School in
Oakville Ontario the man seen in the
photos and videos is a manufacturing
technology instructor who is allegedly
who allegedly began identifying as a
woman last year the teacher now goes by
the the name Kayla Lemieux
quote the kids here most definitely
don't think it's normal but
realistically we can't say anything one
student said on Twitter last year the
teacher was a man I don't think the
school can fire him
now when you hear that it said that you
know the fake breasts he's wearing are
oversized I think then uh if we put it
that way we are engaging in severe
understatement he is in fact wearing
prosthetic breasts the size of like hot
air balloons his inner woman is
apparently nine feet tall and weighs 800
pounds by the looks of it in fact his
inner woman seems to be literally
bursting out of his stomach like that
scene from Alien now and we can make
jokes about this because it's totally
absurd but actually it's not very funny
the kids in his class are not as you
heard from one of the kids they're not
comfortable and how could they be
they're the victims of sexual harassment
here
and they're not going to be getting any
help from the school as Redux reports in
a follow-up quote the Ontario High
School at the center of a controversy
for having a male teacher uh a male
teaching young students while donning a
large prosthetic bus has issued a full
defense of the teacher in newly leaked
emails sent to parents
uh it says quote
we are aware of discussion on social
media and in the media regarding
Oakville High School we would like to
take this opportunity to reiterate to
our community that we are committed to
establishing and maintaining a safe
caring inclusive Equitable and welcoming
learning and working environment for all
students and staff the email reads uh
the school defers to the Ontario Human
Rights Code suggesting that any concerns
about Lemieux would be akin to
discrimination
well we strive to promote a positive
learning environment in schools
consistent with the values of the hdsb
and to ensure a safe and inclusive
environment for all students staff and
Community regardless of race age ability
sex gender gender identity gender
expression sexual orientation ethnicity
religion cultural observance
socioeconomic circumstances or body type
slash size
body type size that's not his body type
though
that's not any human being's body type
this is rather his hideous
pornographic impression of a woman's
body type
it would be no different if he showed up
to class in blackface
okay imagine that he showed up for maybe
it's Black History Month and he decides
to wear black face
only in that case blackface would
actually be a little bit less grotesque
because at least it would not be
presumably it wouldn't have the element
of fetish attached to it it would be
merely offensive and insulting it
wouldn't have the fetish fetishistic
element to it in this case the teacher
is not only making an ugly outrageous
mockery of Womanhood but he's also
acting out a sexual fetish in front of
the students
Auto gynophilia
is a term you should all know
because it applies to a lot of what
we're seeing in the culture although
often it's mislabeled
autogonophilia is when a man is sexually
aroused by the thought of himself as a
woman
it's it's not even that he actually sees
himself as a woman or thinks he is one
but that he's sexually excited by the
idea of himself that way
we can safely assume that's the case for
this guy that we have here a case of
Auto gynophilia rather than gender
dysphoria because of the massive
cartoonish breasts
which by the way are worn with a
see-through skin tight shirt this is
fetishism not dysphoria
what we're saying is that no distinction
is made between those two things because
to the left it doesn't matter
there's no there's no limit to this
you know a teacher could come to school
wearing a strap-on dildo in front of the
students and we'd be told that it's
bigoted to object
once it is declared that the world's job
is to validate an individual's internal
feelings and perceptions
there is no Rock Bottom to that
no basement
we just descend further and further
into madness
now let's get to our five headlines
inside every Progressive is a
totalitarian screaming to get out and
the team at front page magazine has been
unmasking these totalitarians since the
earliest days of the internet founded by
David Horowitz a former red diaper baby
and a new leftist who ultimately became
an enemy of the left and a best-selling
author at the same time front page
magazine has spent over two decades
combating the radical left's efforts to
destroy America there are two new
podcasts the right take with Mark tapson
and the Jason Hill show offer riveting
interviews and insightful coverage of
politics culture and current events you
don't want to miss it the right take
with Mark tapson offers fascinating
in-depth cultural commentary as well as
interviews with well-known conservative
thinkers like Heather McDonald Michael
Walsh and Mary Grabber the Jason Hill
show offers thoughtful deep Dives about
the ideologies of the radical left and
interviews with renowned intellectuals
like Peter wood it takes a village to
combat the radical left's efforts to
destroy America that's why as a fan of
my show you should also check out these
guys over at front page magazine you
won't regret it and you can do that by
visiting
frontpagemag.com and while you're there
support their cause by making a tax
deductible deductible donation look
inside every Progressive is a
totalitarian screaming to get out and no
one understands that better than the
team at front page magazine so go check
out
frontpagemag.com today
so Joe Biden was interviewed by 60
minutes and most of the interview not
very interesting or worth talking about
for the most part but there were two or
three brief moments that I think um are
worth taking some note of so for first
here is Biden responding to his dismal
approval ratings how do you explain how
do you explain the fact that everybody
hates you and um of course the correct
answer is that well what he should say
is I'm a miserable wretched person and a
failure and I'm doing a terrible job and
people are suffering because of it he
could give that answer but that's not
the answer that he gives let's listen to
what he says
your approval rating in the country is
well below 50 percent and I wonder why
you think that is this is a really
difficult time we're at an inflection
point in the history of this country
we're going to make decisions and we're
making decisions now that are going to
determine what we're going to look like
in the next 10 years from now I think
you'd agree that the impact
on the psyche of the American people
as a consequence of the pandemic is
profound
think of how that has changed everything
the people's attitudes about themselves
their families about the state of the
Nation about the state of their
communities
and so there's a lot of uncertainty out
there a great deal of uncertainty
I I love the answer because what he's
what he's saying basically is that the
only way that his approval rating could
be so low is if our entire
National psyche has been profoundly
changed that's the only way like the way
we see our communities the way we see
even our families and ourselves all of
that is Warped and has been shifted and
and everything and that's why his
approval ratings are so low
I mean if you don't approve of the job
that he's doing then it must be because
you your your entire perception of
reality has been
has been somehow damaged
um but here's the part that I think a
lot of people are are making a big deal
about when he's asked if he will run for
re-election and he doesn't exactly say
yes let's listen
sir are you committed to running again
or are there certain conditions that
have to be right look if I were to say
to you I'm running again all of a sudden
a whole range of things come into play
that I have requirements I have to
change and move and do in terms of
election in terms of election loss then
it's much too early to make that kind of
decision I'm a great respecter of fate
and so what I'm doing is I'm doing my
job I'm going to do that job and within
the time frame that makes sense after
this next election cycle here going into
next year make a judgment of what to do
you say that it's much too early to make
that decision on I take it the decision
has not been made in your own head look
my intentions I said to begin with is
that I would run again but it's just an
intention but is it a firm decision that
I've run again that remains to be seen
like I said A lot's being made of this
especially in conservative media
um
that this is well you didn't say it was
going to run again I I don't see it as
anything significant
he he is going to run again okay let me
uh I don't mean to spoiler alert here or
ruin any of the suspense that you might
be you might be experiencing
um but there's no suspense he's going to
run again the only thing that would stop
him I mean literally the only thing is
if he dies before before you know 2024
which he's an elderly man so who knows
you know we're getting up to the point
when it's it's uh you know you get
beyond the average life expectancy for
for a man in this country but aside from
that aside from that or some kind of
truly debilitating Health crisis and I
say truly it had to be physically
debilitating because we know he's got
he's already mentally debilitated that
hasn't stopped him
so if he's like confined to a wheelchair
or something then then maybe I could see
that he would feel he has no choice but
to not run again
aside from that he's going to run and
how do I know that I mean is it because
the the polls are in his favor is it
because he's he there's a good chance
he's going to win well no obviously not
it's just that these people
they don't give up power willingly
um they're not gonna quit
of their own volition
think about Joe Biden he's pursued this
power his entire life his whole life
has been in pursuit of this it's the
only thing he's cared about
he's been in politics his whole life
trying to climb up the ladder
desperately
crawling and kicking and scratching and
everything to get there and then he he
gets there and yeah he's half seen out
by the time he gets there you think he's
gonna give it up
no you got a pride out of his hands it's
the only way that's the only way he
gives it up and it's the same for all
these people
they don't spend their whole lives
pursuing this just to stop
so no he will absolutely run again
guaranteed
finally here's Biden on the uh on the
pandemic what's I mean we haven't heard
much about it recently so what's what's
happening with that let's find out
Mr President first Detroit Auto Show in
three years yeah
is the pandemic over a pandemic is over
we still have a problem with covet we're
still doing a lot of work on it uh it's
but the pandemic is over if you notice
no one's wearing masks everybody seems
to be in pretty good shape and so I
think it's changing and I think this is
a perfect example of it laughs by the
way no follow-up there in case you're
wondering there's no follow-up he says
uh the pandemic's over we still have a
problem with covid but the pandemic is
over
no follow-up like well how do you
distinguish between we have a problem
with covid but the pandemic
is over
what's what's how do you delineate
between those two things
of course I agree with him
that there is no pandemic but then but
then a lot of us have been saying that
for a long time
that's kind of the distinction that many
of us have been drawing for a while now
that yeah covet exists it's it's a
problem in the in the sense that it
exists it's out there people get sick
there are lots of diseases that are uh
that are that are like that
that are endemic they're a problem
because people get them and they get
sick
but is it a is it a pandemic is that
something we have to we have to live
every day worrying about we have to uh
structure our life around it no
but up until right now the message from
the Bible Administration has been no
covet is it's still we're still in a
pandemic I mean they've said exactly
those words we're still in a pandemic
we've heard that time and time again and
now all of a sudden the 60 Minutes
interview he says oh it's over actually
and what we hear from the from the noted
journalists there is no follow-up just
oh okay well it's over then
so it's over now when when did it when
did that when did when did it end that's
a question
that question is not asked oh it's over
well when did it ended how do we know
that it ended
and why did it end then and not before
all the time that you've spent saying
we're still in a pandemic like what
changed between then and now
doesn't ask the question because we know
the answer of course it's um
you know not just a fortunate
coincidence that the pandemic ends quote
unquote right before the midterms
what do you know just we're uh we're you
know
a few weeks out from the midterms and
that's when the pandemic finally ends
how fortunate for the Democrats this is
from daily wire it says Martha's
Vineyard residents congratulated
themselves on their behavior after the
arrival of 50 illegal immigrants sent by
Governor Ron DeSantis the immigrants
arrived on September 14th by September
16th they had already been uh bussed to
Joint Base Cape Cod Rachel self and
immigration attorney who insisted that
the immigrants have been kidnapped
declared we've got their backs and
they're not alone
a local volunteer said of the community
the year-round Community is very strong
because you're kind of isolated here
whether it's the ferry or the bad
weather you're stuck here
uh they said quote we're used to helping
each other we're used to dealing with
people in need and we're super happy
like they enriched us we're happy to
help them on their Journey
um the Martha's Vineyard residence by
the way got the memo because when uh
when the illegals first arrived
they were not happy and they were
complaining about it in front of cameras
and then they saw the reaction on social
media and they realized okay we got we
got to put on a happy face here and
pretend that we're happy about this
oh we we're very happy to help them on
their Journey
their journey by the way is to be
deported to a military base it's to
enlist the military to get these people
the hell out of here
oh come on everybody we're going to help
you all my latinx brothers and sisters
coming we're going to help you on your
journey let us guide you by the hand all
the way yep over here over here right
okay off the island completely
just shove them off
that's what Martha's Vineyard did they
had 50 illegals show up and within 48
hours they had them on a bus stay the
military there and they don't want to
bust to a military base
and now they're congratulating
themselves we help them on their Journey
oh that's you know if that's all it
takes like if we can start deporting if
we can enlist the military number one
to help us with the Immigrant illegal
immigration problem and just start
busting these people out of here
if we're able to do that as long as we
call it helping them on their Journey
I'm fine with that maybe that's the
compromise well stop calling it
deportation and we'll say it's um it's
uh
Journey assistance I don't know we think
of a better title
a local church
um a member of a local church echoed
this sentiment saying actually people
here really give a damn they really care
you know what this is why the the the
political message I think was very
successful
I mean yeah they're after they've gotten
rid of the illegals and sent them to a
military base now the residents of
Martha's Vineyard are trying to uh
pretend that they were not distressed At
All by the by their presence and they
can do that all they want I don't think
anyone really Falls for it
but I think if you actually want to send
the message home if you want to make it
very clear then keep sending them
I mean we just heard from Martha's
Vineyard residents that they're more
than happy to help they're happy to help
on the journey they're it's it's they're
they're it's a different culture up
there with all the rich people on their
Island they're isolated they're
different from everybody else
they're better
well okay well then send them more
keep sending them send it send a 100
next time and the next day send another
100.
now whatever the the population is on
Martha's Vineyard match that in illegal
immigrants and then we'll see
we'll see how long this happy face can
uh can maintain
because that's really the point here if
you're for um States down in the South
and for Border towns it's it's not like
they get 50 illegals and then that's it
for the year
no it is a constant never-ending stream
of thousands and thousands and thousands
of these people and that's when it
becomes an overwhelming problem
so I think these Republican Governors
that are shipping the illegals to you
know Martha's Vineyard or Chicago or DC
they're getting the point across but if
you want to really get it across you
can't stop you got to keep doing it
and um
I think the residents of Martha's
Vineyard again they've given you the
excuse they've they have said that
they're they welcome it
so they have no right to complain now
they've now they have officially invited
more
all right
uh Bill Maher has gotten himself in
trouble with the left yet again for um a
monologue he delivered on his show on
Sunday
and he's being accused because of this
what you're about to hear because of
these remarks he's being accused of um
of white supremacy and and actually
justifying slavery
but let's listen and find out if that is
a fair characterization
did Columbus commit atrocities of course
but people back then were generally
atrocious
everybody who could afford one had a
slave including people of color
the way people talk about slavery these
days you'd think it was a uniquely
American thing that we invented in 1619
but slavery throughout history has been
the rule not the exception the Sumerians
the Egyptians the Greeks Romans the
Arabs British the early Americans all
the way up through R Kelly
come on
[Applause]
the Holy Bible is practically an owner's
manual for slaveholders the word slave
comes from slav
because so many slothic people were
enslaved and there is white as the
Hallmark Channel
who do you think gathered the slaves
from the interior of Africa to sell to
slave Traders Africans who also kept
their own slaves
uh and the whole monologue is quite good
it goes on for about eight minutes it's
worth listening to putting aside the dig
at the Bible there which is silly and
not true
the rest of it
I basically agree with and it's also not
true that people back in in earlier
times were generally atrocious it's not
like they weren't worse people but they
lived in a different time they lived in
a more brutal time but generally
speaking the message there I agree with
it in fact it might remind you of
something it might remind you of a
monologue that I delivered on this show
very recently you know it's very similar
now I'm not accusing Bill Maher of
listening to my show I would never
accuse anybody of that but we have had a
similar conversation and I'm glad that
Mars talking about it it's important
because it helps us to actually
understand
historical events when we put them in
context
right you can't you can't understand
anything about history until you
understand the context
of the people that you know the context
that people lived in back in those days
it's funny in fact that the left
cares deeply about context
when we're discussing say the brutality
of modern day criminals non-white
criminals anyway
so if we see another one of those videos
of uh some someone who's out on bail and
has a lengthy rap sheet just randomly
brutalizing someone or there was one
recently of a
someone robbing a convenience store
and putting the the cashier on his knees
and then executing them shooting in the
back of the head
of course that person lengthy rap sheet
criminal I think that person was out on
on bail I believe
many videos like that whenever we see
these videos what we hear from the left
is that um well we have to understand
the context we have to understand it the
systemic racism and and all the things
that they've suffered in their Community
we have to understand that
and the context becomes an excuse that
lets the criminals off the hook and back
into the community to victimize even
more people
but then somehow they're totally
uninterested in analyzing the context
for anyone who lived on earth prior to
the Modern Age so people that are living
today some people anyway get the benefit
of context
but nobody who lived before us gets gets
the same
Grace
they're all expected to just know better
but with that attitude you can never
understand history and if you refuse to
understand history then it's it then
studying it is pointless and impossible
there's another reason why this matters
also it's that
uh
you know it can give us an opportunity
to analyze ourselves
like the fact that everyone in the world
supported slavery
for thousands of years
that almost no one voiced any objection
to the practice in principle now there
were people who objected to certain
elements of the practice and and
objected when it was particularly brutal
but as far as someone saying slavery
itself is wrong
human beings are all equal like that
sort of thing there was almost no one
making that claim for thousands of years
of human history across the entire world
and that fact ought to make us reflect
on ourselves because it goes to show how
powerful
a dominant cultural narrative can be you
know it's the power of of the spirit of
the age
if everyone accepts something
everyone is does and nobody questions it
then it's very difficult to view that
thing in a critical light
because you don't have you haven't been
given the framework
for being critical of it
everything you've ever encountered every
opinion you've ever heard
everything around you serves to
reinforce this cultural narrative
and this force is so powerful that it
even protected slavery from criticism
for millennia
now
I think a lot of modern people they tell
themselves
they say themselves well
if I was born 500 years ago I would have
known better
everyone that existed in the world for
thousands of years they were all morons
if only I was there I would have told
them I would have known
but you almost certainly would not have
known better because you only know now
that slavery is wrong because everyone
you've ever met from from birth onwards
believes it was wrong and told you that
you were told from birth that it's wrong
you didn't you didn't you don't you
don't get any credit for that Revelation
other people had that Revelation and
it's correct it's a it's a it's a
correct right and they passed it on to
you they told you
everything in your life reinforces the
idea that slavery is wrong thankfully
so given that you've existed in this
context it's just meaningless to declare
that you would have arrived at the same
conclusion had the context been exactly
the opposite of what it is today
now the point here is not relativism
okay it's not that um
it's not that uh slavery was okay back
then because everyone thought it was
if you're a relativist then that would
have to be your conclusion we're going
to talk more about relativism in the
daily cancellation but if you're
actually a relativist and if you believe
we all get our own truth and there's no
objective truth then you then you of all
people have no basis for condemning
anyone really but especially people in
history and especially when it comes to
something like slavery because it was
their truth that slavery was okay who
are you to say otherwise
but I'm not a relativist I believe there
are there is objective truth and
objective moral truth
um and it was objectively wrong even
then but the point again is just to
understand the power of a dominant
cultural narrative so
here's one way
to know
that you would not have opposed slavery
if you're asking yourself would I have
opposed slavery if I if I lived 500
years ago or 200 years ago or a thousand
years ago
well here's one way to know that you
would not have opposed it
if today all of your views and beliefs
and ideas
and opinions line up perfectly
with like Disney
and Apple
and Hollywood movie studios
and the people who run Twitter and
Facebook
okay if everything you believe lines up
perfectly with those organizations and
and and what they profess
then you would have supported slavery
a thousand percent certain that you
would have how do I know that because
because you are the sort of person who
simply accepts and adopts whatever ideas
are dominant and popular and supported
by the cultural institutions of the day
it's it's not a coincidence it just it
just happened to be that you that your
point of view your world view lines up
perfectly with all of the dominant
cultural institutions
no it's a they told you and they are the
dominant cultural institutions they're
the most powerful institutions in the
country they've told you what to believe
and you believe it
and if that's the case then it only
stands to reason that if you had lived
in a time when all the most powerful
cultural institutions said that slavery
was okay you would have believed that
too
now the powerful cultural institutions
say that uh that women have penises men
can give birth to babies there are lots
of people in this country say well I
guess that's the case then
Twitter wouldn't lie to me about that
all right a couple other things I want
to mention before it gets the comments
section uh
scrolling up to this this is from Fox
News it says not a single arrest has
been made in the more than a dozen
attacks on pro-life pro-life
organizations across the country claimed
by left-wing pro-abortion group Jane's
Revenge Jane's Revenge has claimed
responsibility for at least 18 arson and
vandalism attacks on crisis pregnancy
centers and other faith-based
organizations throughout the U.S since
the May 2nd League of the Supreme Court
draft opinion in Dobbs the FBI first of
all Fox News digital in June
that it had launched an investigation
into the targeted vandalism the FBI said
in a September 7th statement that it was
still investigating the quote series of
attacks and threats targeting Pregnancy
Resource Centers and faith-based
organizations
but it made no mention of Jane's Revenge
specifically even though again James
Revenge has
I mean it's they've been very open about
that claiming credit for this and
they've made threats and they've carried
out those threats
so this is It's a group of people who
have announced themselves
they haven't told us who they are they
haven't done all the FBI's work for them
but they've announced themselves and
they said this is what we're doing we
are breaking the law we're engaging in
this Terror campaign
um and here we are
the FBI told Fox into digital in an
email the incidents are being
investigated as potential acts of
domestic violent extremism
um and face act violations that's the
freedom of access to Clinic entrances
violations or violent crime threats
depending on the facts of each case
the FBI takes all violence and threats
of violence very seriously and we're
working closely with our law enforcement
Partners at the national state and local
levels to investigate these incidents
however when you go through each of
these incidents
and there are over a dozen of them 18 in
fact
what you find is that no arrests have
been made at all
so it says the first of the attacks
occurred on May 8th that Wisconsin
Family action in Madison which was
firebombed and vandalized with the
threat if abortions aren't safe then you
aren't either
no arrests have been made in that case
which is still considered active police
told Fox News digital
um Wisconsin Family action president
Julian Appling told Fox News digital not
only have no arrests been made but to
the best of my knowledge no Person of
Interest has even been apprehended or
brought in for questioning
so they haven't they haven't identified
anyone remotely connected to it they
haven't questioned anybody yet the
investigation is ongoing sure
um
Appling said she hasn't heard from any
federal or local authorities regarding
this case since early June
the same day of the attack at Madison
Jane's Revenge posted its first
communique on the anonymous blogging
host
noblogs.org with a picture of the
vandalism and demanding quote the
disbanding of all anti-choice
establishments fake clinics and violent
anti-choice groups within the next 30
days
and they continued
um Jane's Revenge claimed it carried out
the vandalism uh on May 14th at Alpha
Pregnancy Center in Reisterstown
Maryland
the Baltimore County Police said an
arrest has not been made in reference to
this case
there was another one in Saint Michael
Parish in Olympia Washington
investigation is still ongoing no
arrests have been made they told Fox
News
and then you go down the list
so we have all of these cases of of not
just threats not just violent threats
but actual crimes that have been carried
out
and there has been a failure
on the local and federal level because
it should be
uh
you know it should be the local police
investigating this
because it's a it's a crime it's
vandalism it's arson
but then it's also a federal crime too
it's terrorism it's a hate crime and as
uh as the FBI spokesman noted it's also
it is a it is a violation kind of
ironically of a federal law which was
passed back in the 90s meant to protect
abortion clinics and this is the very
same law that um gives this kind of this
this Halo this uh
this ring of protection this force field
around all abortion clinics
where if you want to go and pray outside
of abortion clinic you can't get within
whatever I forget what the you know
certain amount of feet you're not
allowed to get that close to the to the
entrance of the abortion clinic even if
it's not their property
so for any other institution yeah if
they don't want you on their property
they can tell you to leave but you can
stand one inch away from their property
and because it's not their property
abortion clinics are given this
extra privilege of being able to kick
people off of property that is not
theirs because it's close to their
property
and this all ties back to this federal
laws face act it was passed back in the
90s
well in order to make that law seem um
less biased
they threw in something in there that
also protects pregnancy centers
uh that makes it a a federal crime to
attack or you know set a pregnancy
center on fire
they didn't think they'd ever actually
have to enforce it they just put it in
there uh you know just put it in there
to make it as as to save face basically
well now it's actually happening
which means that federal law enforcement
and local law enforcement should be
looking into this and yet they've made
no arrests at all
are these I mean who are the people
doing this are they are they ninjas I
mean are these criminal masterminds
couldn't you just start with look at
there's their security camera footage it
shouldn't be that difficult to track
this down
a lot of these things are happening in
cities and neighborhoods where there's
security camera footage all over the
place it shouldn't be hard to go look at
the security camera footage at least see
someone we haven't even seen any
uh videos or photos of of of Persons of
Interest
nothing
and I think we all know why that's the
case
all right let's go to something that's
um
uh
people on the left are are saying is
worthy of mockery this is Utah State
Senate candidate has earned the mockery
and Scorn of outlets like The Huffington
Post here's a sample headline Utah GOP
candidate Rhymes police and free speech
and cringe-worthy rap video this went
viral on Twitter and people are making
fun of it it's a Utah State Senate
candidate
um
who is
announcing her entrance into the race
through a little wrap and a little bit
of a dance that she put together let's
watch it
hey Utah District 12. listen up right
here there's a new name on the ballot
for the Senate this year my name is
Linda Paulson Republican and awesome
love God and family and the Constitution
I tried to get another conservative to
rent nobody could do it so I'm getting
it done I'm pro-religious rated pro-life
pro-police the right to bear arms and
the right to freeze feet I want less
government control and regulation want
to stop and expose all political
corruption with Integrity morality
accountability government programs
should lead to self-sufficiency and
support traditional family as the
fundamental unit of society but in
schools they are pushing for new beliefs
and just to clarify that's a female
adult I know what a woman is
there we go I download that on Spotify
put it on my playlist look
uh
is that embarrassing and cringe-worthy
yes
but I'm gonna allow it because I think
it's embarrassing and kind of an
endearing way you know because she's a
grandmother and so she's embarrassing
it's like she's embarrassing her
grandkids in the way that all
grandparents are supposed to now if
she's 30 years younger it's it's a total
disaster but given that she's a sweet
old grandmother it's kind of funny and
wholesome it's wholesome it's
embarrassing a cringy but in a Wholesome
Way so I'll allow it
in fact I would even say that we should
we need a lot more corny right-wing
grandmas in local offices that's exactly
what we need I would say
so in this case
I have made I'm I get to make the
determination here passing down the
verdict and that is allowed
so it has been declared let's get to our
comment section
[Music]
before we get into the comments uh I
don't think I need to set this up too
much Ben Shapiro visited the studio R
Studio recently and has a special
message for the sweet baby gag
we can all watch now together
no longer is anything can happen to
tired cliche it's morphed into the log
line of a horror movie titled modern day
America the daily wire was born out of
this cultural reality because just like
our listeners we were tired of having
our intelligence insulted we were tired
of the overly simplified good guys
versus bad guys Paradigm that plagues
politics that's why we strive to make
the most Innovative and culturally
relevant content in the world and Matt
Walsh has stepped up to that challenge
in ways we couldn't have imagined he
couldn't have imagined it either what
started as a podcast recording in a
parking lot has blossomed into millions
of subscribers a best-selling children's
book a groundbreaking documentary film
and an entire gang of sweet babies
Matt congratulations on all of your
successes and many more to come here is
to another thousand episodes
there's the walrus the giant stuffed
walrus actually it's right there you
can't see it on camera but it's been in
my peripheral
this whole time a little bit distracting
the end of The Saga
an olive branch
from Ben Shapiro no apology
there's no apology no admission of guilt
it's unfortunate but I get my walrus at
the end there and that's all that
matters
and you saw I mean I told you that thing
is a giant this whole time I've been
talking about now you see you see it for
yourself
and you know what
my sweet babies we fought for this
um we dedicated ourselves
ourselves to this cause
I don't want to get emotional about it
but
I just wanted my giant stuffed walrus so
bad and now I have it and now I can
bring it home
and I can put it right in my living room
a centerpiece a focal piece A
Conversation Piece
just as my wife always wanted
actually she's dreading this day so I
moved from one battle the battle
actually is not over at all I moved from
one battle to an entirely different one
when I lug this giant ridiculous thing
home which will happen later today I
look forward to that
all right scotch and ribeye says
ironically I agree that parental consent
should be irrelevant regarding gender
affirming care for minors these insane
practices should be illegal regardless
of whether or not some nutcase parent
consents to it uh consents to it being
done
Well I obviously totally agree with you
um it you know this is not the kind of
thing that a parent can consent to on
behalf of a child
but removing parental consent
makes it all the more horrific because
what that means is that if a parent does
object and says I don't want this then
and I'm not going to do this to my kid
and I'm not one of these nut case
parents that's trying to indoctrinate my
kid into it quite the opposite um those
those parents can now be dismissed
as we saw from the you know wpath
guidelines we talked about on Friday
and according to them their new their
new guidelines they're uh they're so the
the advice because they don't have quite
the power to actually pass laws but they
can they can come up with guidelines
that then the other medical institutions
organizations all adopt uncritically
according to them yeah parental consent
matters it's important as long as the
parent is saying yes and agreeing with
us and if they're not then it doesn't
matter because that means that they're
abusive
T biscuit says personally I've never
heard of a human who referred to
themselves as a sexologist and wasn't a
pervy scummy human being I'm sure there
could be decent sexologists out there
but the name has such negative
connotations for me now
and for good reason does it have
negative connotations but there are some
exceptions one exception would be
Deborah so who's in our film what is a
woman and she is a
sexologist and a scientist but
um
one of the few who's willing to
criticize gender ideology
um Darcy says I laughed so hard at your
son calling people humans your guy's
conversation shows your personality so
vividly your son gives reasoning just
like you yeah the funniest example of
this actually is we went to a restaurant
a couple weeks ago and it was mostly
empty I'll walk it in there and um my
son goes there's only one other human in
here
except that it was actually like six or
seven people in the restaurant
which made me think okay what are the
other people if they're not humans so do
you know something you're not telling me
um
and EPO Rose says Matt in The Princess
Bride the gatekeeper's name is Yellen
and the albino at least in the book is
his cousin so it's quite possible the
albinos family name was actually yelling
is that true are you lying to me is that
actually true I got to look that up I
don't I'm I'm a big fan of Princess
Bride I think it's one of the better I
think it's one of the best movies ever
made in terms of rewatchability but I
guess I'm not that familiar with the
backstory
you're saying the the the the albino who
runs
the torture chamber his name might
actually be yelling
and last week I observed again not as an
insult whatsoever but I observed that
Janet Yellen the treasury secretary
looks a lot like the albino who runs the
torture chamber in Princess Bride and
now you're telling me that they might
actually share a name so I was really
onto something that's incredible
well though he was the perpetrator and
source of excruciating pain for me
personally at long last as we just saw
Ben Shapiro made the right decision uh
he made the Humane Choice albeit someone
selfishly to give me the walrus back I'm
not gonna give him a lot of credit for
that but I did get what is rightfully
mine I'm not sure if this will make me
eligible for workers comp but this has
been the most torturous thank you gift
I've ever received to all those who have
been holding out and standing in
solidarity with me it's time they're
suffering and self-deprivation have come
to an end you don't have to hurt anymore
not for me we can heal together I
finally have a walrus
my life is forever changed for the
better because of it so go get your own
at dailywire.com shop today also here at
the daily wire we've been rapidly
expanding our Creative Marketing team I
want to call on my sweet baby game
creatives to head over to our career
page and check out our open art
Direction graphic design and Studio
management positions this is a
fast-paced environment so if you thrive
on that you'll do well here if you're a
lazy bastard we don't want you I think
it's time for my SPG call to take over
the daily wire headquarters we're
already taking over the world now we've
got to take over the daily wire next
just understand that as your leader I
will expect a lot from you luckily we're
a meritocracy here so to whom much is
expected much will be given head over to
dailywire.com careers to view our
openings and to apply let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
well if you watch my film what as a
woman then you're familiar with the
lengths people will go to deny objective
reality I asked one young woman in the
film what would happen if my truth was
that she no longer existed and she
immediately replied that uh if that's my
truth that that she doesn't exist well
then she doesn't exist
such was her commitment to the
relativistic viewpoint but since the two
of us were standing in the same physical
environment and having that conversation
in the first place
does that not indicate that there is
some sort of shared reality that we both
inhabit and since that reality has
certain laws certain immutable features
does that not again indicate that there
is one truth one reality filled with
lots of people who all Harbor ideas and
opinions which may or may not comport
with that reality
that's not what is that what it means I
mean after all no matter what your truth
might be we all still live in a world
where two plus two equals four
or do we
Ontario math teacher Heather
I'm not gonna even attempt the last name
thighs buyer thymeyer Maybe
well whatever uh she says otherwise in a
tweet reposted by Chris Ruffo Heather
who again teaches math to kids
wrote quote there are many math
education practices that we white folk
don't see as racist or supremacist
because they're so ingrained in our
background and experiences and we've
been the ones to benefit from them she
then thanked someone named Jason too for
shining a light on these examples of
mathematical racism she then provides a
chart in the shape of a pyramid
which distinguishes between overt white
supremacy in math education and then
below that she has covert white
supremacy in math education now examples
of overt white supremacy are things like
racially segregated classrooms
which by the way is something that only
the left actually supports anyway and
also she says the n-word uh the n-word
is is an example of overt white
supremacy which is a good tip for any
Math teachers out there do not
incorporate the n-word into your math
instruction
just so you know don't do that if you
find yourself shouting the n-word while
teaching long division
something has gone horribly wrong
Heather points out and I'm glad that
she's here to clarify that point but
then we move to the covert examples
and there we find a bit of a mixed bag
so she says that standardized testing is
white supremacy which is good news for
me because I always did very poorly on
standardized tests as a kid which I
guess means that I'm not a white
supremacist
of course there are many valid
criticisms you could make of these
standardized testing approach and
especially if a system structured around
standardized testing but people like
Heather make those conversations
Impossible by insisting on racializing
everything as always
she also says that the phrase um stick
to math is white supremacy and we could
maybe spend some time reflecting on how
stupid that is but we have bigger fish
to fry because she also lists two plus
two equals four
as white supremacy
yes only in a white supremacist Fantasy
Land do two things and two other things
equal four things
if it wasn't for white supremacy two
apples and two apples would make nine
apples or 12 apples or three apples in
Orange and five coconuts two and two
apples would be a whole fruit salad if
not for white supremacy
now if this seems to make no sense at
all
that's because it doesn't make any sense
but I think In fairness I should let The
Advocates of this idea explain it for
themselves unfortunately the teacher who
posted this tweet locked down her
account so we don't know what else she
has to say the guy she credits for
having shed light on this
um Jason too I went to his account to
see if he's explained it
and he in fact said that he's um he's
not going to explain why two plus two
equals racism
he says we should all simply accept it I
guess because he said so
he did however retweet a different math
teacher by the name of Lori of Laurie
rubell who posted a thread on the
subject and here's what she said
what does the two plus two equal four
talk mean here we go again
she didn't post a meme and explains in
the caption here's one way that two plus
two equals four gets used
the crowd of people has gathered holding
signs with various alternative equations
the one guy who apparently knows the
truth is being excluded slash derided
and called a Nazi that image isn't
actually about math it's about truth who
holds the truth who decides what is true
and how open are we as a society to
multiple truths
does this mean that anything goes no it
does not
here's another Insidious way that two
plus two equals four gets used it's used
as a kind of basic truth and way to
ridicule many critiques of mathematics
as white and Western and as exclusionary
are those critiques suggesting literally
that two plus two is anything other than
four no
okay so then what does it suggest I mean
what do you what the hell are these
people babbling about
well Laurie then links to a different
thread that she wrote on the same topic
about a year ago which tells us this
the two plus two equals four talk
signals that there is a single truth a
single way of looking at things a single
correct way to live or be rather than
multiplicities of all of these matters
since math is endowed with social
Authority and positioned as objective
and as part of a natural order
that then implies that the singular
approach is also part of the natural
order that's why people reference two
plus two equals four in racist
anti-trans anti-queer talk Etc because
in their view opening up Math and how we
teach it would imply a challenge to a
natural order they hold a sacred one in
which white people and usually men are
at the helm
okay so in other words they can't
explain why two plus two equals four uh
it means racism because the claim is
abject nonsense
this is the way it always goes with
these academics like they make some
absolutely ridiculous statement and then
either refuse to explain it insisting
that their mere assertion should be good
enough for us that we should bow before
them intellectually and accept whatever
tribe spews from their pompous
self-satisfied mouths or else they
pretend to explain it but in reality
they're simply just talking around the
issue going off in half a dozen
different directions and at the end of
it all we're left with an assertion
layered in a bunch of other assertions
with nothing in the way of an argument
much less a proof or evidence to be
found
now in this case there are really two
claims being made
one is that there is no objective truth
and two is that asserting an objective
truth is racist
and they don't explain either assertion
and of course they don't actually
believe either of them either
because if they did for one thing they
couldn't possibly teach mathematics
every this is the whole point of
bringing up two plus two equals four in
order to explain that objective truth
exists because every math lesson would
consist of them just sitting in front of
the class and saying whatever you think
is true is true you all get A's
congratulations
now we may be getting to the point where
school will be taught that way but we
aren't quite there yet which means that
they do believe in objective truth if
they teach math to teach something means
that you believe that there is an
objective truth to be taught the very
Act of teaching means that you are
affirming that there is a truth
because if there isn't that means that
you're just what trying to get the kids
to accept whatever subjective point of
view you have
what's the point of that that seems a
highly
uh egotistical
also I'm willing to bet that if either
of our friends Laurie or Heather ever
encountered say an actual white
supremacist I mean a real one like an
actual klansman
one of the four who exist in the country
would they not be willing to agree that
the guy's worldview is true on on any
level I mean would they affirm his world
view
would they give him the benefit of of
his own truth
no they wouldn't in fact they would
insist that he is both factually and
morally wrong about everything he
believes
and they would condemn him accordingly
the only way that you can condemn
someone for their worldview or their
racism or bigotry is if you are
asserting some factual and moral truth
that you expect them to comport to and
conform themselves to
in fact
um they even for people who aren't
klansmen
they'll do this the very statement
two plus two equals four is white
supremacy that in and of itself is an
assertion of Truth
everything you heard in the explanation
wasn't absurd as an assertion of Truth
and it all rests on the belief that
white supremacy whatever it is is bad
which is also an assertion of Truth
so they do believe that there is a truth
there's an objective truth a reality
that we all inhabit
which has not only scientific and
physical laws but even moral laws
it's just that they're very selective in
who should be forced to abide by these
laws
so this is racial paternalism cloaked
and so-called anti-racism which is to
say it's just anti-racism because that's
all anti-racism ever is
now
briefly leaving aside the problem that
these people don't actually believe
anything that they're saying
and also the problem that you can't deny
objective truth without asserting it at
the same time
because saying there is no objective
truth is an assertion of an objective
truth so but leaving all that aside
I want to focus
um on on one thing Lori says in her
explanation
again quoting the two plus two equals
four talk signals that there is a single
truth a single way of looking at things
a single correct way to live or be
rather than multiplicities of all these
matters well right this is exactly the
problem
she says that two plus two equals four
signals that there's a single truth well
yeah it does and that's the point
there's one single truth and in that
truth which is the only truth two things
combined with two other things make four
things
but then she goes on and says that there
that it also signals that there is one
way of looking at things and one correct
way to live
but it doesn't signal that at all
and and the truth the the way we look at
things and the way we live these are
three categories they're not all the
same
they don't belong in the same category
the truth is just the truth it's the
reality it's the state of things
that's what the truth is
and it persists it maintains no matter
what we think or how we live
as far as as far as what we think and
how we live we have lots of freedom in
that regard not complete freedom
I I can't live at the bottom of the
ocean I can't live on the moon the
reason I can't live that way is that
physical reality otherwise known as the
truth precludes it but within certain
parameters I can live basically how I
want and I can certainly think what I
want yet I cannot
through the power of my thought
or the manner of my lifestyle change the
fundamental facts of reality I can
choose to acknowledge those realities or
not
but the realities persist
this is how the relativists play the
game they conflate reality with
perspective and lifestyle they assert
that because there's a multiplicity of
perspectives and Lifestyles there must
also be a multiplicity of realities but
then of course by trying to create more
realities they actually erase the
multiplicities of perspectives
because what they're actually asserting
is that each reality has has only one
perspective and if you have another
perspective then you exist in a
completely different reality
what they're saying is that in in this
the reality that I'm in there's only one
perspective anyone anyone has a
different perspective and that they they
Branch off to their own we live in this
Multiverse and uh and each Multiverse
each little Universe in the Multiverse
is populated by one person
you only get one perspective for each
universe
information
the relativists cannot explain their
arguments they can't defend to prove
them
they don't even mean most of what
they're saying and they can't help but
contradict themselves a dozen times in
one sentence
it's a mess in other words
and it is why they are all today
canceled
and that will do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to our members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
hey Utah District 12 listen up right
here there's a new name on the ballot
for the Senate this year
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]